stormy morning off the north coast of
northern ireland gale force winds have
prompted an amber
warning here for the last couple of
hours meaning there is a risk to life
and the police service of northern
ireland is warning it's going to be a
very difficult commute this morning
storm franklin hit the west coast of
ireland late last night at one point
seven counties in the republic of
ireland were under an amber alert they
were measuring waves at 42 meters right
in the atlantic at one point and that
you can see just how stormy it is here
in county anthem this morning some 4 000
homes are currently without electricity
across northern ireland and i understand
somewhere in the region of 29 000 homes
in the republic of ireland are without
power and it's a similar story right
across the united kingdom it has to be
said we've had some pictures in from
scotland uh where the waves are crashing
onto the promenade at our drawston
harbour ferry crossings from belfast to
scotland and indeed from belfast to
liverpool have already been suspended
not that i'm sure passengers will be too
disappointed when they have a look at
these pictures
there's been a disruption to flight
transport as well of course with flights
grounded in some cases at shannon
airport in ireland and diverted to
dublin in other cases and england won't
escape this either of course there are
two severe flood warnings in place
around manchester field operatives at
the didsbury flood basin sent some
pictures in as well and the environment
agency is urging people to follow all
advice and to evacuate immediately if
they are told to do so
there's also a problem with regard to
the number of roads now blocked across
the uk and ireland that's not a surprise
given that trees will have been weakened
by the two previous storms several of
them have now uprooted and the fire
service in the west midlands says two
people had a very lucky escape when a
tree fell on their car near sutton park
so this third storm in the space of six
days is continuing to wreak havoc and
it's going to really add to the
difficulties of those who are trying to
restore power across england following
uh that record 1.4 million customers
being without power after the storm used
to so i think the message is really
simple here uh from port russian county
antrim unless you really have to leave
home this morning don't
okay but you really had to david so
thank you for going there for us much
appreciated of course we'll keep an eye
on what's going on for you the latest
from the met office let's have a look as
you can see it covers most of the
country winds from storm franklin
bringing possible disruption first thing
before easing through the day a met
office amber wind warning covers parts
of northern ireland until 7 a.m where
damaging 80 mile an hour gusts are
possible
a yellow warning covers more of the uk
until lunchtime where gusts will widely
reach 50 to 60 miles an hour locally
higher ireland has similar warnings